[Music]
I'm not mentally well I haven't been for
a while it feels good to say that I
probably come across as I had normal
kind of guy but the truth is I often end
up she's sobbing in my bed like a baby
there's a lot of pressure these days to
be a real man my dad would have called
me a [ __ ] if I'd known how weak I feel
sometimes
ice to be fine I was doing well and work
felt invincible but I started getting
paranoid I'd get paralyzed and start
feeling dread something bad was about to
happen to me for me it came from nowhere
if you told me a year ago this would be
me today I probably would've laughed III
used to think it was a kind of excuse
people made to get up for work I have to
take a whole lot of pills every morning
and I wouldn't be speaking this calmly
if if I didn't do that but it that way
on a bad day I hate myself
Ivan tell you how much but even telling
someone
it helps so much
I had a full-on panic attack here's this
big family gathering there to call an
ambulance and I'm still not well I can I
look okay but I'm not and people knowing
that about me that was like part of the
Cure you know that there's so much
secrecy and shame
it makes such a difference to know that
there are people like me I feel like I
can really call these guys my friends
now we talk sometimes we take a piss
and then sometimes when it's bad we need
to yeah yeah I said I can call these
guys any time you know cuz they just
know what I'm going through
we don't have to like be cheerful around
each other we can just meet up and not
even be very much it's just nice to know
that we know what we need
it is pretty simple men killed
themselves that's why we need this you
know we need this dis [ __ ] matters you
know in some men you know things could
go to pot and they want to take their
life there's they don't think to you man
call for help you know we we can take
medication for our physical health you
know why why should it be any different
for our mental health yeah absolutely I
mean I think this is the problem it's as
important for more important than your
physical health it's people are afraid
to acknowledge it yeah what we're saying
is no one's beyond that help and and
maybe if us who are coming out and
sharing this if that makes one person
admit that they need help as well then
then it's all worth it
our book what is psychotherapy tells us
exactly what going through therapy is
like and why it is so important
you